venti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
io sono felice ed oggi siamo qua con
nichi dies la bruttina grazie
praticamente a video su flash royale
io non so neanche come si accende crash
roiate quindi oggi qua per spiegarmi
come funziona clash royale
ma tutto questo bordello di roba va
fatta in un certo modo perché se io
sbaglierò qualcosa dei suoi insegnamenti
questa roba caimano nichi è un collare
elettrico con il quale lui mi può dare
la scossa
apri mente c'è questo telecomando di
merda che io devo tantissimo che lui
userà per darmi la scossa in caso io
sbagliarsi qualcosa si direi che
possiamo cominciare ragazzina l'aveva
non fosse si arriva al cervello
qual è il cervello ma allora non ci
riesci a stare rilassato così col
collare una 2000
partiamo questo telecomando di merda
lodo a nichi o non far karate moreno
devi far niente mette insieme a quello
che fa e questo che facendo niente
cosa fare allora adesso noi abbiamo
davanti un baule magico andiamo ad
aprire questo baule mesto desiata cosa
c'è dentro è dentro ci sono delle carte
lo ha prima intenzione perché se non
trovino leggendaria icona leggendaria io
ti prego dio lo fai attenzione ai 7
possibilità ok allora c'è sempre
leggendaria questa guarda che quest
guardo lo incontrano camera per luccichi
qua scheletri comune con grandissima
mina la ra ra riot tra le cose questo
perché ci ha i baffi non è perfetta non
erano tre rara aia
dai amore mio ti compri un pacchetto
nuovo confronto malissimo
ora di gara che la cosa più bella del in
chiave a questo male chiara marca [ __ ]
volte forte ma mica non lo puoi
abbassare per davi che va fa malissimo
la prima denuncia fosse comunque 4
congelamenti erano buone [ __ ]
facciamo battaglia dai da andiamo su una
battaglia sei pronto
no posso staccarlo a metterlo nel
braccio rolex berlesi allora picco
ghiacciato allora io parto subito subito
in der beek arcieri al cerea aspetta in
uso troppi danni secondo me e pertanto
portarci lo schermo si pensa che cazzo e
numero di spiegare bene se per di ancora
tempo mi sa che ti eri così la scarica
che this minchia sul film mamma mia
quanti la vecchia e magari touch il
tronco punto c tronco ci trovo è che le
opzioni in ora che barba discenti sono
troppo forti devono fare qualcosa
il patch e la siamo cavata abbastanza
bene che pecca di quello non è il pecca
lori questo enel e gas serra e mega
sgherro
allora mettiamo queste che sparano le
frecce le mettiamo qua ci pensa che su
un album e poi c'è questo che attacca
dietro fatto però adesso tank a lui ed
alimenti qualcos'altro
questo mega scazzo lasme tronco il nonno
e non il pugno mancano casi salvata
consiglio in una sola volta che il culo
di ma grande e adesso d'attacco mini
pecca tutte le principesse si sa è un
gruppo di atti nato sono forte comico
tronco il tronco che gli svincoli a ahia
ahia
dietro a me la velocità i gamberi
dall'odio hai perso hai perso quindi
quello finale hai aspettato che può che
valuta crash royale recensione ma no
[ __ ] a chi mi dà le scosse a cazzo
cazzo
puoi fare un'altra partita se volo un
medico messo come tempo
apriamo dai primo il baule bassa di
bauli e di fidati abbiamo il burro e del
clan dove qua paura del clan
raga los aprendo per la prima volta
andando che si ma epica sono almeno ed
epica in poi sono già pi che mai dai dai
paranza per danone cup tarara dai giochi
di merda tornata ultimi anni la donna
che culo è ma perché c'è questo non è
che tra l'altro viene anche da cinque
scheletri giganti bellissimo ma poi
andate ben più belle baule queste c'era
un attimo dove poi ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato ma vabbè contare che giocano
tutti quei barbaricina
subito a me prenderei un ascom fidi di
me sì sì ma di martire avete i falchi o
se era partita da lì tra di ross per
kiryat ahia ahia
che culo vuole bene
grazie a cinto madre dietro così mi
chiamarlo anche i tronchi possono
distruggere il coso da che vinco dai che
vinco una volta vento che spirava vinco
tranquillo e bolla come non sai cosa è e
cosa è il coso lì che fa questa la
chiamo operativo tronco perché è assurdo
sono assurdi questo
ahia ahia ahia si fanno male toccano mai
stanno facendo fuori tutto sti stronzi
posso giocare io sto gioco brutto non mi
piaceva neanche prima sgherri ai a dio
quanto manca tipo 10 9 8 7 7 6 5 4 posso
ancora vincere aspetta la scarica gesù
cristo
ma la cosa più bella è farlo attendere
perché lui non sa quando io farò la
scossa che in questo momento che a [ __ ]
nichi l'ultima va vinta l'ultima va
vinta perché se si vince l'ultima porta
2 farà porco 2
vai vai sono contro quelli stone mito
valchiria subito dai donatori subito
avviato le subito di arrivo io a vincere
in 3 secondi
allora io mi difenderò ci sono le cose
lì sono gli scheletri cosa faccio kagami
no dai dimmi qualcosa di milano
la proviamo a fare un tentativo di alghe
lover solo perché rosa regista jager
lower è un gioco devi indovinare chi ha
avuto più ricerche nell'ultimo mese
subito capito che fai che se io sbaglio
ci sia la penitenza
allora microsoft word o george michael
non lo so perché non so se aggiornato
adesso via d'esame aggiornato adesso è
sbagliato la vita è una merda la vita
ahia ahia ahia ahia basta neanche uno
giusto né poste ring non so cosa sia
quindi whitney houston che meno male
troppo bene poste ringo judo per la
mossa di judo
ok ok per forza com'è possibile che mi
hanno messo al gioco non è possibile ma
tanto tanto lavoro ma storno ragazzi a
posto adesso di chi sbaglia arrivato io
per il raduno nota testa fatevi le
orecchie isis al disaster
chissà che disastro ci siano android
questo 135mila nepal earthquake
terremoto nel nepal quando c'è stato c'è
stato ahia ahia ahia ahia dai detriti
che si arriva via dieci aerei salvo che
non ci sei
no all'acqua vedete il numerino che è
sempre stato a uno come quindi con lui
un bel 100 che hai ricevuto 100 volte
ricerca del pezzo di pane ragazzi e che
possiamo dire grazie a dio vi chiama
sono mai stato contento di finire quindi
abbiamo fatte tante
mentre assicura rimasto vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio nichi parlami insegnato a fare
qualcosa su presso gli altri con la
grazia di dio non c'è verso dai ragazzi
sono in questo video di saper scelto
cose trovate i link in descrizioni anche
del canalini chiedi non passate la
gronda non è brutta qui niente ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto un settore un momento e
mi piace anche ai vari social comunista
kim hughes pictures angelo sinisi
aderisci vi chiamano così video e le
ragazzi che tra l'altro sto telecomando
è quello del televisore questo che
adesso che sono tornato a casa mia per
questo natale
ogni volta che per il mosto tasto mi si
spegne televisore cosa hanno chiesto che
venga come succedeva negli ultimi
quattro anni liquidi beh ragazzi vedi
che funziona